we now have to talk about california
governor gavin newsom and that means
that i have to put money in this jar
because i'm mentioning california and
gavin newsom soulless
extra five today solus gavin newsom the
american psycho of politics someone who
will say and do anything absolutely
anything uh to attain power someone who
as we showed you on friday when joe
biden was out of the country magically
showed up at the white house to meet
with joe biden's wife dr jill biden and
meet with the vice president they are
planning a slow-motion coup joe you just
don't know it well anyway gavin newsom
was in the news not only because he
showed up at the white house but he did
an interesting uh interview
with la television and also he's been
going after ron desantis and and he
dares occasionally say the word freedom
which is a word that should be banned
from his mouth because he does not
believe in freedom at any level
whatsoever well he did an interview a
couple days ago on la tv and uh it turns
out that in about a week from now it's
looking like la is bringing back mask
mandates yes what a time warp we live in
well he was asked about that
la county has moved from medium to high
risk for the spread of the virus the
nation's most populous county is
preparing to bring back an indoor mask
mandate if the covet search continues
this morning here in la county the
nation's largest county home to 10
million people we could be two weeks
away from reinstating an indoor mass
mandate here l.a county looks like it's
about to put in a mass mandate back
when
the rest of the state is not
does that make sense to have certain
parts where you can literally go across
the street you got to wear a mask and
and other places where you don't is that
a good policy at this point in the
pandemic look
localism is determinative this is a
bottom-up frame the end of the day i
keep reminding people because i keep
reminding myself california's the size
of 21 state populations combined
the conditions up
in northern california near the oregon
border very different than they are in
the southern part of the state and so i
do believe in regional approaches i do
believe in flexibility at the local
level now you see the exact opposite
mandates denying flexibility at the
local level coming out other states
we believe in a different approach so i
think that needs to be tailor-made
through the elective process and the
delivery process at the local level i do
think that's more appropriate okay i
want to be very very clear and clean
with my words here
it is my belief as a free citizen
of the united states of america
that gavin newsom does not have a soul
i think it is possible that he is not a
human being i think perhaps he is some
sort of cylon or alien
or per maybe was created in a lab
somewhere
but that is not a human being his
ability to lie
with no
clearly
no thought into what his actions are and
how they differ from his words is
absolutely incredible so he believes in
localism he locked down his entire state
now when they're trying to bring back
mass mandates then he's sort of into it
oh yes they should be able to do it
they're deciding what they do locally
but let's just flash back to a year ago
if a year ago if one of those counties
up near the oregon border had wanted to
not lock down he would have been all
over them so he's a liar the idea that
he cares about bottom up governance is a
complete lie he loves big government he
loves high taxes he loves more power
from him for himself did he believe in
localism when he was dining at french
laundry without a mask with lobbyists
did he then when he was locking
everybody else down
didn't stop him from spending 30 000 on
booze at french freaking laundry uh i
don't know how you can i've said this
before i don't know how someone
look we can all make mistakes we can all
regret decisions we've made we can all
evolve politically certainly all of
those things are possible he is nothing
other than a high level
fraud
con man everything about him everyone
needs to know it you need to tell all
your friends because he's obviously on
his way to the national scene right now
they are trying to figure out a way when
they get biden out to make him vp and
then maybe they'll push kamala out so
he'll be the the democrat nominee in
2024 so that they can actually push
california policies all over this
country he has demolished california
california in the last two years had
never before the last two years had
never once had a net loss of population
twice in a row last two years 2020 2021
uh they have lost population these
people are going all over the country to
get away from him and his policies so i
just don't understand how you could say
that i believe
in localism no you don't nothing that
you have ever done has shown that you
believe in localism that you believe in
bottom-up framework you liar
but this is what they do these people
are hypocrites they are bs artists and
it never ends